okay thank you very much
uh so welcome to march's
uh town fun board meeting for clay cross
uh if we can maybe start with apologies
for absence is daemon on the line to
give the
status uh no parties have been received
chair
yeah perfect thank you very much then
move straight on to
declarations of interest from the points
on the agenda today
is any member have any interests
or other interests that need to be added
to the register for today
don't see any hands raised so i'll take
that as a no and we can move straight on
to
0.3 minutes of the last meeting which
took place on the 6th of november last
year
i believe the minutes are a true
reflection of the term fun board meeting
that we held in november and would like
to move them to
be added to the record me in a minute
any objection so anyone second that
andrew king you have a question of two
seconds
you're on me at the moment
at second second minute thank you very
much
okay then i'll move straight on to
the good news of the meeting uh if i can
hand over to is it
called in the funding announcements uh
yes thank you chair
um so as i'm sure you've all seen um the
press announcement we
secured 24.1 million
which is absolutely fantastic news and
all down to the hardware
cup effort on the board and nexus
planning who obviously helped pull
together the town investment plan so
yes it's fantastic um results
three of the 10 projects have conditions
attached
and so we have to respond to those
within the next
three weeks i believe now creme if i'm
wrong and so we've got
conditions to respond to on those and
but they're they're not particularly
onerous in terms of conditions so
what we'll do is and we'll pull together
a response
and we'll share it with the chair and
vice chair and then if need to be the
wider board
and then we can get them submitted and
to say that we
understand and these are our responses
to the conditions
the draft heads of terms is with our
legal department as we speak
so they can read through it and um and
there's no the ins and outs of it all
but yeah so the
take-home messages is 24.1 million
absolutely fantastic news
and they're all down to the board's hard
work and nexus as i say
uh comment from yourself melanie
sorry i didn't get myself off me yeah
morning everybody well just
congratulations because it is just
amazing news so
really and the fact you got name checked
by the chancellor as well
um during his budget speech was was just
icing on the cake
um so just in terms of of the work going
forward
and you've got until the 17th of march
to actually agree to the
to the heads of terms um or agree to the
offer
but then you've got two months um within
within two months or you haven't
accepted the offer
that's when you've got to to address the
um conditions
and obviously provide some other
information um around the
the projects that you intend to take
forward so there's quite a few
steps um to be taken so i think
once you know it's probably be helpful
if i can sort of have a conversation
offline with carl and
um jill about you know those stages
go through um but yeah all in all it is
just
um really positive i don't know whether
anybody's got any particular questions i
don't know
carl of the heads of terms being shared
with um
the board
yeah yeah so i think it just really so
if you have anybody has any questions
i would look at the heads of terms it'd
probably be worth sharing the business
case guidance as well
so that you can see the two things in
conjunction um
and then if you have questions then just
do get back to me as soon as possible so
i can
you know give you some answers hopefully
so chair allen i'll circulate both
documents after this meeting
thanks a question or comment from andy
james
thanks guys which projects had the
conditions on
do you want me to follow are you going
to do it
i was going to but if you got it to hand
me you can do yes
i have yes so it was the low carbon
housing project
the low carbon energy network strategy
and the rail station feasibility study
okay thanks melanie
okay thank you any other comments or
questions
sorry chair i just i just wanted to
thank melanie also
for helping us guide us through this
process and
absolutely thrilled um to hear the news
um
very exciting for clay cross and the
district
and look forward to continue working
with you in the future and
thanks to all the board really really
chuffed
yeah that really is a thanks to everyone
involved it's been a
yeah a long slog to get it all done but
it's excellent results
uh really really promising from the the
area in general so
well done everyone there's no additional
comments we can move straight on to
the accelerated project which is point
five uh again called like to continue
i'm sorry comment
no i'm trying to clap using being clever
using the reactions and i can
i'll put it on and i can't get it off
now
because it is quite an achievement i
don't think you should underestimate
it compared to what some of the other
councils got we've done very well
exactly yeah thank you okay carl
j um yeah so as
you're aware we was we received a half a
million pounds
to um accelerate some projects to aid
the delivery of the town investment plan
and we had four projects identified and
the first one was a bridge street depot
and which is opposite tesco's i'm sure
people aware
of the the depot itself well
we took the decision that the depot
um was past its best um and
wasn't fit for purpose so we've
um taken the the decisions board to
demolish the the um the depot
which um if anybody's been near clay
cross recently we'll see that it's well
underway
the last uh last update i had was
there's one building left on there
so that's moving really well and then
the next stage will be putting planning
and looking for low carbon usage
commercial space on there
so again it fits with that gold thread
through the
uh clear costar investment plan of that
low carbon
um energy usage on on the on there
demolition did form a junior school and
also purchased a formal constabulary
building
as we're aware because of the nature and
complexity of those
pieces of work we weren't able to do it
within the original march deadline
however um we have been
given permission by mail and the funders
that were able to roll that into the
next financial year so that works
uh underway so we've got some additional
surveys to finish
at the um junior school and then that
work will progress
and we met with county council yesterday
they had a really productive
conversation around the constabulary
building and
and the purge of that but then the
really exciting bit
is the art project so that's something
that um
personally i think is is something
that's going to happen it is having an
immediate
impact on the people of clay cross
i see it's the the mine shafts or the
ventilation shelf sorry
have been replasted and in a position
that you can have
a live project projected onto there
so that's something that originally we
wanted to to purchase the equipment
to make to keep it and then to do the
art project after that point and then
use it further on down the line
it's not impossible for us to be able to
purchase that equipment in the longer
term
so it is going to have to be dedicated
to this art project
and as you can see from the report some
of the feedback
we've been receiving is absolutely
fantastic in terms of the engagement
with
young people in the area and the
difference is it's making and that's of
helping to pull together that they are
work for there
part of the issue though is it is a an
aspect called an event if you will and
which is really difficult to do
in the middle of a pandemic when and
we're not allowed to
have people meet or be be near each
other
so the suggestion from the people who
are doing the work is
is to delay the the final light show on
there
um until there's a point where people
can actually
attend and be engaged fully in it
and we now have the road map handily in
terms of where
we should be and hopefully get that
route out of the pandemic and
into a position where it's we return to
some sort of level of normality where we
can actually
move past the rule of six and you know
have that mixing
outside so the ask of the board
is um are you comfortable as a board for
us to delay
the light show from the planned time to
later on in the year when we
pass that road that road back off
i've seen a few heads nodding already so
um i'll leave it there so are you happy
for us to delay the light show until
we're out of the pandemic
good thank you just a slight update from
when that document was put together
called
the proposed dates from the additional
arts and the local arts are the 22nd to
the 26th of september
deliberately chosen when the when the
kids have gone back to school because a
lot of the children have contributed to
this
and it'd be a good idea to let the
teachers remind the kids to remind the
parents
to get that buy-in from the community to
go actually and see this as well
yes council renwick yeah that's a really
good idea
you know it's sadly a lot of us haven't
got across to clay cross
because of the because of the lack of be
able to move around
to see this but the pictures that i've
seen absolutely stunning i think they're
amazing
and i've just wondered whether we could
actually um
in one of our meetings meet some and the
people who contributed to it
um just to just show our thanks and
appreciation but
yeah i was i'm really impressed with the
images
on the uh on the ventilation shafts yeah
that's really good and they've also
proposed doing some
work in between now and then to generate
the interest such as
exhibitions in the library or putting
some
uh displays in the church that type
thing at a social center
so that's a really good idea as well
andrew king yeah you're a meet again
sorry andrew
um can you hear me now yes okay yes
thank you and carl i just wondered
whether you could just give a little bit
more
information on the constabulary building
i i understand that as you say the
demolition of former junior schools not
going to take place now
until until next year but then what's
what's the position with the repurposing
you're going to be
understanding the formula
at this point we're discussing with dcc
that the mechanism
to get the building valued
and then the process of how we would
transfer the ownership
and then the idea is that the consumery
building would be in
northeast district council's ownership
and the um countryside service would
then stay in there until at such a point
when it needs to be used
for as part of the town investment plan
uh work
that we're looking to do so at this
point it would be
sort of business as usual for probably
a year maybe a little bit longer and
then at that point we can start to see
well how does it fit into that
investment plan how do we
make it part of that creative whole area
work that we're doing around that sort
of area so
um you wouldn't see much difference in
the first instance
um because countryside service would
continue to operate out over there
until we're at a position where we're
ready to to move the business cases on
and
turn that into the next phase of his
life really
so but the plan is to repurpose it it's
not it's not to demolish
yeah sorry yeah yes it's not there's no
plans to demolish it it is to be
repurposed
sorry okay any further questions
and if not then i move that we approve
the decision
for moving the date of the light
projection
say cancel right away second in that
thank you very much
and then we can move straight on to the
working group
updates uh maybe is that jill could you
give a
update on that
i think the working group update is carl
rather than me apologies carl
it's all right
actually i believe the working group
update was um
council renwick apologies
past the past hunted yeah
group so we're going to have the
communities and the suggestions
yes
we agreed the number of working groups
to go with the
10 streams of of the bid um you know
and actually um without a shadow of
doubt the
announcement this week just shows us the
the amount of positive pr
communications that we should be uh
getting out from this
this project we have 10 projects so i
despite the announcement of just the
actual bit itself we've got all the 10
other strands of
of pr and i know that um nexus
and the council did quite a lot
consultation
um during the run-up to this and it's
obviously quite
difficult in the constraints of covet
and but i do think that um the community
uh engagement's gonna be really
important going forward because
obviously
people are gonna start seeing activity
in our town people
would now be well aware that that we've
got the funding something's gonna happen
we've
got quite a number of people actually
contacting the council in terms of
investors in business so
this is already positive and so we're
proposing to set up a
combined communities and communications
working group because it that helps us
as a board to
you know it's not it's quite a big ask
for all of us to get
to to reach every part of the community
so the idea is we have a
somebody to lead on that we've got in
mind and i'd like to
propose that counselor alan powell who's
our cabinet member for
um communications and um and
communities he's an experienced um
editor of two very well known sheffield
um papers in his past previous
employment and he has a good handle on
this and i think it'd be quite good for
him to help coordinate
i'm keen to make sure that all the
community groups are
able to feed into this and um
it's in the paper that's set out today
it's actually condition of the fund
anyway
and i just think this is the best way to
actually um improve our communications
and community engagement would be to
have this working group
sitting alongside the other working
groups and um i hope
i can have someone to second that and um
that the board agree
as a strategy going forward is that gary
thank you gary
a second from me so anybody want to ask
any questions about that or and if not
be happy to to support that
i've got i can see very few people
actually don't mind everyone's
blank towels i don't know if damon's
able to
uh can i caroline sorry it's nigel very
nice
to see you yeah i don't know how many
people you can see on your screen i've
just put my camera
uh i just wondered how how the
the paris council and i know jerry's on
on the on the call
uh fit into that you know the the
communities and
all that i don't know i've asked him
passed and uh
i don't know you know it's a joint thing
but i just wondered if there's a
there's a role for the parish councilman
well that's exactly why it's communities
and
and communications because we recognize
that whilst we have
um one representative from the parish
council and
a number of councillors it was to
broaden it out to the wider
so so there's opportunities for others
from
the parish to join for instance so that
gives it more practical
you know we want as many of us as
possible need to spread the word so it's
getting the right people
into the mix carl thank you if i can
food yeah um
a couple of the local councils have
already
expressed an interest in joining so
councillor vida and council
around supposed asked if they could be a
part of that group and
so that i think that's an important link
between
clay cross and the parish and the board
thanks pal i noticed jill also had a
hand up
sorry i was just going to say that i
think we slipped into the uh
consultation uh reports and i just had a
few other things to say about
that is that are we are you happy chair
too
for me to talk about the consultation i
am yesterday
um so just leading on from what
councillor renick was was saying
um in that report um
it also covers about a consultation
strategy going forward
and it's going to be a really key part
of managing and getting buy-in
of the community and businesses
to deliver the wider aspirations for
clay cross
so in that report you will see at the
the end there is a
very very basic comms plan for this
which will get populated by that group
um and what we are looking for
is um
people to to sit on that group so we've
got the two
councillors now uh from who reckon the
parish on the district
i believe um we've got councillor
uh powell who has got that experience to
share it
what we would need is somebody from
um this board to be the link to feedback
into into the board about what's
happening in that
um work stream going forward um
because all the work stream the people
on the board
a number of them all sit on the work
streams and they will be
being asked to feed back into this board
so that's somebody needs to consider who
needs to sit on that
um and we will be looking to go out to
get
uh businesses um in the area that
that are comp savvy really to help us
spread the word
and come and ask to join that workshop
the board itself is big enough so this
is an opportunity for other people to
get involved
um and influence what what's happening
so we're talking to just you know so
we're talking to a number of um
businesses this after well i'm talking
to a number of businesses this afternoon
that we may
look to see if they'd be interested in
joining that work stream
um can i just put a plugin for those of
you that
are on linkedin clay cross
towns fund has now got a linkedin
profile
that we are trying to spread the word
about what we're doing to look for
investors and we're out to procurement
for
um the consultants to do this next pace
of work
so if you're on linkedin can you link
link to the clay crosstowns fund please
and start spreading the word through
your networks
yeah that's a very good point jill um
actually all the
various social apps um do media apps and
i spent i think the kind of uh
budget day evening um circulating and
pressing forward on on facebook
facebook twitter and linkedin and i've
actually had some responses through
linkedin
i think um it is what's written again
that we are getting
businesses and investors actually talk
to the council
so so we this is really positive news
that
you know people are hopefully getting
excited as we are about
um what clay cross is gonna how it's
gonna be transformed going forward
so it is incumbent on all of us to try
and do our bits you know the movers that
can
get out the message and share the share
the story
the better
a question from andrew king
yes uh through the chair to the council
runway
um yes i think it's enormously important
the communications
to uh the community uh
how well that now looked because it was
going to give an eyesore so very nicely
painted was there any possibility that
we could
consider a projection uh on there
of um an update
because they they will take notice of
what they see
uh on on signage and something like that
particularly
uh as a projection i think
it would have a initially a novelty
to it
i think we always have the art group to
this forum and yeah i
imagine that you know lots of uh
streamers and and
uh the big announcement yourself being
on there for for a few you know if we
can get that sca
get that make that happen just to let
people actually know that
you know 24.1 millions coming to us and
it is
you know it absolutely should be used as
an information sharing um
you know how to connect to us where to
come to us in terms of
being part of it or or you know feeding
into
people into what people want to see so
yeah i think that's something that um
hopefully comes and communities group
can do and that and i think that's the
point i think that's what i thought was
an important
additional group to our working groups
because there's going to be so much
information
i mean the art project itself needs uh
you know we could we could make a lot of
publicity out of
that in itself you know i think people
see you know i did an interview with
bbc derby and um they mentioned it
so i was able to actually talk a little
bit about you know hopefully people play
prosper to see
the art projects on the ventilation
shaft so it's already you know
so yeah absolutely i think we have to be
imaginative i think that's why it's
important
to have the community communications
group because
we all have our parts playing the the um
you know the
the bush telegraph from some councillors
and the
the various groups is is a really good
way to you know talking to residents but
also there's
the more modern modern media social
media and
things like the ventilation chef's pr
all add to that i think we have to be
broad and wide and that's why i think we
need a little bit more
expertise to make sure that um we are
reaches as far as possible and
as jill pointed out the draft gen the
jeffrey gender pad
we've only got a bit as a small amount
of population what we're going to do i
expect that
to be highly more populated by the end
of um
this next 12 months when we started to
work on projects
and the topic of the production andrew
has been discussed with regards to the
the town fund plans and unfortunately it
has to be done for the production to be
really effective
so it's something that we're looking to
do between segments when they do the
exhibition on the
22nd 26th of september so it's
definitely an idea that we've we've
looked at and we'll be doing
uh but whether we can have something a
little bit more permanent
is a little bit more challenging but
certainly something else
thank you question from melanie
yeah just just to say that the mate
there's still support available
for you from the town's delivery partner
and certainly with regards to sort of
consultation and stakeholder engagement
there are resources available on on the
townsfond website that would
just help with that so it's worth when
you touch base with them as regards
with phase two support do consider
backtracking and looking at the support
that's already there in terms of
consultation etc thank you very much
okay so i think we've covered topics six
and seven this unless you've got
anything to add to the
communication strategy jail
well complete good thank you then i'll
move over to point eight on the
on the agenda uh board members
recruitment
councilor renwick did you want to take
this one
no i think this is carl because i don't
apologize i haven't got
the um some reason i haven't got the
packs i haven't got the agenda
no problem and if i i can pick this up
chair
if required so as you know we
went out for advert for additional
uh private sector board members um
because i think we all recognize that um
the pandemic meant that some of our
private sector partners had to focus on
their business
because of the nature of the industry
they were working in
uh the the people we've um spoken to
um really will add value actually
and but it was felt that they may be um
more suited to working on one of the
working groups
and that's partly because of the the
challenge that they have in terms of
the land that they own and the interests
they have within clay cross
means it'd be really difficult for them
to assist in the board if we're then
making decisions around
their land or um anything where they
have
a significant financial um interest in
so it'd be unfair
on them and i think in terms of
transparency for
the wider um playgrounds it might be um
quite challenging to uh to see that
somebody potentially may benefit and it
could be
seen to be the the board has facilitated
that so what we're going to do is ask
these people who
we've got really development skills to
join a working group so we still
capture that and that need and ability
that they have and can bring to the
board
but not in a position where they're
going to be um
not able to participate fully uh that
being said
however there were um there have been
other people come forward
since then and there's three of them two
of them so far
have met with the chair and vice chair
um
and um they seem to have all the right
skills again
and interests within clay cross but not
in such a way that it would make it
impossible for them to fully engage with
the process
one is a business that's just outside of
clay cross
but obviously draws um a lot of their
their work
workers from clay cross and have an
interest in the area
and we're keen on promoting not just
the part that they work in but also clay
cross as well
so as part of terms of reference and it
is a board decision
and it requires a report to be submitted
so
if you if you don't mind share i was
going to suggest that i
write a report um identifying who the
the board members potential new board
members are submit it
to the uh the board and i'll do this via
email because
we don't want to wait until the next
board meeting because at that point then
they're missing out on joining so
between now and the next board
i'll submit that report if you can
respond via email to say
yay or nay and if it's a nay it'd be
fantastic to understand the rationale
behind it and because it
it has felt that these people will bring
the relevant skills
and ability and business know-how and
that public website private sector
uh focus and lens to the work but also
um
they're not in a position that they
they're not going to be able to
fully engage because they're conflicted
in such a a difficult way
so if i can't yeah that's my suggestion
is is that
something that's acceptable to the group
it's it's been a number of months that
we've been a little bit light
on business representation so it'd be
really beneficial to get this moving
quickly so
i would totally agree with that call
so if we can do that in the next couple
of weeks that would really help us out i
think
as a group yeah yeah no problem i'll
i'll circulate that report
and thank you okay
thank you very much uh moving straight
on to the clay crosstown investment plan
the way forward
i've got jillocard for this topic
it's me i think so uh within your pack
uh which is item nine um it's just
understanding what our next steps are
we've discussed quite a few of it but i
think it's worth um if you go
to page 24 of your pack you'll see the
flow chart and it's a picture we can't
we're not sharing screens today because
i think it's quite important to see how
far
a journey we've come
and if you look at that um all the
stages we've already come
through are there and we're down to
where the star is and that takes us
just over two and a half pages there's
an awful lot of work being done
to this stage is it possible to get that
on screen at all
so let's see if i can share oh no i
can't if i have to be
asha just bear with me
thanks joe
i think you're right seeing it on screen
jill does help a lot yeah
can we put it on page 24 please
and make it slightly bigger
thank you lovely
so you might remember that um we
we put this together um i think around
the time i
joined the council which was last may uh
just so everybody understood whether
where we'd come from and where we were
going
um so you just start scrolling down i
won't go through everything but you
you can see that you all got together
back in december
november december 2019
and since that time an awful lot of work
has
gone on carry on um
joe and um
a lot of work during the summer where we
did consultation
on the plan plan then got submitted
towards the end of uh the year so we
went for the december
deadline and the star
is where we are up to now
so um we have been allocated
the funding but we have to go through
certain hoops now
um to actually secure that
and that involves us getting
the business cases sorted for each of
our 10 projects
and as mel said at the start three of
those projects
um it's not exactly a question mark but
we need to give some more information on
them because they're not as clear as
what
government would like them to be about
what what how that works
um now in the next
few months what we will be looking to do
is um and appoint consultants
so we were out to procure consultants
now because the government have a set
form of how the business cases need to
be done and it's uh
it's a five case business case
um and you have to meet certain criteria
and meet
government guidance it's quite a
specialist area and so
we'll have consultants in to do that to
work at those business cases and to make
sure all the finance is right
the economic outputs are right that
we've got proper consultation that
everybody's on board with that so that's
what we're going to be doing over the
next
few months we have 12 months to do
that so as as um mel said we've got
three weeks to sign the heads of terms
then we've got um is it two months or
three months after that mail
to work with those gray areas of those
three projects to
get some clarity on that and then we've
got 12 months to start working on those
business cases
now some of our business cases are much
more um
worked up than others so for instance
charlie park
has been worked on well before the
business um
that this work came out and what we're
being told is that we may be able to put
certain business cases as a group
forward
earlier than the mate but then
the rest we can't do them one by one but
we could put a group together to take
them forward
earlier so i think at some point we'll
probably come back to the board if we
think that's a
something viable because what we can
then do is get
accelerate delivery which would be um
suit a lot of people i think um to see
delivery earlier on
later um do you want to carry on
down thank you so
um the final business cases will be
probably about 15 months 16 months
for the the main part if we get some of
them earlier
great we will look to do that um and
then we need to
there'll be a little bit of two in and
thrown i shouldn't imagine so we get
clarifications around our business cases
and what it actually means
and then uh the money would then not to
be allocated and we have to
for those heads of terms it's kind of
like an illegal agreement
um between about how we will use that
money and then
basically when we've done the full
business cases we get the
money allocated but that comes with
conditions that we use it for those
purposes
um and so that's kind of what we're
we're looking at at the moment so
this board will be and all those working
groups will be
working on those business cases with the
consultant
to bring back to the board for approval
um
mel have you got anything to add to that
oh
yeah sorry okay my hand down um yeah so
it's i think you've got you've actually
got to the 17th of march to
to accept the offer and then you've got
two months to put in your
um you've got a form that you need to
complete from
the annex a of the business case
guidance which kind of does a little
sort of breakdown of each of the
projects that you're
preparing to take forward and at that
point then you can identify those that
you might want to accelerate
so some people will have done that in
within their town investment plan itself
but there's a stage now where you can
can identify those projects that you
would like to
to accelerate um the information that
you're going to be providing within that
um with that acceptance by the broad
i don't know what we've actually called
it don't think we've called it
you're accepting the offer and then it's
sort of conflict it's confirmation as
those are the projects you're taking
forward
and at that point you will be telling us
some information about
the match funding the expected outputs
and outcomes of your projects
and again whether you want it to be
fast-tracked and also that breakdown
between capital and revenue
funding within your overall ask but
don't
don't be too concerned about that
because obviously
we recognize that a lot of that
information will still be indicative
until your business cases are worked up
so there's an opportunity then when you
submit your final summary of all your
business cases
to actually identify
the actual information as it were should
i say for
those items so so don't be too concerned
about what you're putting in those
initial
uh confirmation documents for your
projects because we recognize there will
be some
some movement as you develop your
business cases and there is plenty of
scope as you go through this process
for changes to occur as well
so if you there is an instance where you
decide not to take a project forward
there are
points where you tell us that there are
points where you can you could introduce
another project
um and there are you know points where
we would look at changes to the projects
that you're keeping within
in your program so it's just reading
that business case guidance
carefully and then obviously just
keeping that open dialogue with us
um as you go through the process
okay joe could you stop sharing
okay everybody needs to mel
is that helpful is there any other
questions around that side of things
that anybody's got
i think it'll all become a lot clearer
when you see the business case guidance
or not for the case maybe yeah and also
just to say that there is monitoring and
evaluation guidance
on its way as well i don't quite know
the time frame for it but it's certainly
a document that is is more or less close
to completion
and i do i believe that the town's fund
delivery partnership have actually
already
run a workshop around the monitoring and
evaluation for this program
so tap into that as soon as possible
because obviously that is something
that's going to be important for you as
your business cases are developed
thank you tommy you've got your hand up
there
yeah i was just going to say actually so
from our point of view we've had a fair
bit of experience of going through these
processes and
working through it at the left so more
than happy to help uh where possible
and help you to any advice you need on
the process
or business case development and then
we're here and available
to help you along that way yeah
thank you very much if there's no
further questions we'll move on to point
10 of the agenda any other business
if we have no questions on our topics
then just before we
i'm sorry do you have a comment there oh
no then just before we close the the
live feed
does anyone have any comments to add to
the the funding announcement does anyone
want to say anything to the the general
public before we close this from the
those viewing on youtube
in that case is it possible to close the
live feed now due to we need to exclude
the
the public um to avoid issues with
disclosure for
exempt information
you